foreign
hey everybody what's going on it's
Tuesday and we're talking about another
movie and I'm almost going into the
video next you're going into the video
next door next door
one of these days I'm gonna make a video
that's like us and like I'm gonna put a
video over here it seems like you're in
the middle of the screen though I'm not
no I'm not I'm in the same place
I'm always okay that sounds like a you
problem that sounds like a you problem
me talking back
or what I'll be talking back oh you got
oh you gotta you gotta I got one a cheap
uh Power yeah right what do they [ __ ]
what do they call those
intense
intense that's some [ __ ] the dollar
store that's a dollar store one dollar
I mean they all taste like ass to me it
tastes like Sweet Tarts yeah that's they
all taste the same I've never like had
one that was like if it was any better
than any of the others uh no I don't
mind I don't mind as good as the other
one I don't mind the coffee ones like
yeah I like that but like
even those I'd rather just have this is
just coffee this is like the dollar
store brand
and they have two other flavors that are
[ __ ] the purple one and the red one
they taste terrible this is the the
orange one yeah probably it's no it's no
Asian experience that's for sure
it ain't no Asian experience
oh my God uh so yeah hi everybody
um David June said I'm hoping this will
begin a slew of Tarantino reviews we
actually
um are doing this one because uh our
friend Louie sent us Reservoir Dogs and
Pulp Fiction yeah like in a package
yesterday so we were very excited about
that and then we were kind of talking
about True Romance and I was like well
maybe we could do that one too even
though I know like Tarantino just wrote
the script like he didn't direct it Tony
Scott directed it but that was still
like a good movie that I haven't seen in
a long time and I was like really
excited to revisit Reservoir Dogs
because it's probably been at least
I haven't seen this in 25 years I don't
think I've seen it since I didn't see it
in the theater 90s yeah I kind of feel
well no I think I saw it in the 2000s at
some point like but it's been a while
it's been like at least 15 years since
I've seen it we can do some Tarantino
stuffs not as long as it's not his real
ridiculous [ __ ]
it's just [ __ ] ridiculous
um
uh his best stuff we can do but you see
the thing is is uh the [ __ ] my phone's
right it's your phone okay
um
the thing is is that we we still got to
do Godfather one and two well two and
three we did we did Godfather one yeah
yeah two three I know I feel bad because
like we got sent those and we did it we
did the first one but I think we sent
those two I think Louis sent those two
yeah but I was like I said I was just
excited about
you know doing Reservoir Dogs and I was
primed to see uh
Godfather Two I I always remembered
Godfather 2 being better yeah everybody
says that yeah okay
uh David June says do Pulp Fiction next
also digging Tom's New Look been gone a
while yeah I was gonna say you haven't
been here for a little while yeah
because you've been uh had the bald head
and the Magna merciless beard for a
while now yeah well I don't know how
long it's been it's been a while about a
month maybe oh it's longer than that has
it been longer than that it's yeah it's
been way longer than a month I think
I don't know
I'm not worried about it I don't care
I don't care yeah I'm not worried about
it I don't care no he doesn't care about
it I don't care what I don't care about
the beard
we'll use this I'm just let it roll okay
yeah but uh yeah so Reservoir Dogs
Quentin Tarantino's first
I guess kind of like his first
feature-length film I think he had made
like kind of another indie film before
this I read that it was called what was
it called like my best friend's birthday
or something like that but
um that was technically feature length
but I think most of it's been lost so uh
this is kind of like his big debut I
kind of feel like and I had forgotten
like I remember when this came out and
like what a big deal it was I had
forgotten like what a massive massive
cultural impact this movie had just on
independent filmmaking in general you
know what I'm saying it's so different
from everything else right it's like
crazy now like it's crazy to me to think
now because when this came out in 1992
like people were flipping the [ __ ] out
like when it played at uh Sunday ends
when it played it uh like the canned
film festival and stuff like people were
just like everybody was talking about it
was like a massive deal and one of the
things they were talking about was one
how violent it was which by today's
standards it's not really
um but for back then I guess it kind of
was and uh all of the swearing in it
which again I didn't barely even notice
because I swear more than that all the
time too but like racial slurs well yeah
which which that's that's another kind
of Tarantino yeah kind of Hallmark I
guess but it's just this was almost kind
of like the thing that brought
independent filmmaking like up to the
same level as big Hollywood Blockbusters
I don't think that because I think it
had kind of been two tracks before like
Independent films got like a lot of play
and stuff but like a lot of people
didn't see them or it's like they wasn't
but I think when this came out and then
particularly when Pulp Fiction came out
which was also kind of like an
independent film but then it it got
nominated for like best picture and it
was like this big huge deal and then a
lot of people went back and saw this one
too I kind of feel like it was really
I don't know it like it really changed
the way Independent films were marketed
it really changed the way that they were
perceived I guess
I saw the movie as kind of an exercise
in how to make an exciting gangster
movie without very much action in it
right didn't really cost much to make
this just a bunch of gangsters so I
could talking to each other
about [ __ ] about this job that went went
down and um they're mostly just talking
to each other they do have some action
scenes yeah they're shootouts they're
shootouts and stuff but they're mostly
talking with you but it's real
it seems like there's a bunch of action
in it it's real exciting what they're
talking about
and then um they get sidetracked a lot
talk about they were talking about
Madonna they were talking about there's
actually a funny story she was that all
kinds of weird well there's a funny
story behind that because like the
opening that famously the opening scene
of the movie is all of them in a diner
and they're trying to and Quentin
Tarantino opens the movie like you know
Mr Brown and he's talking about how like
a virgin in the song is actually about
um you know like someone with a real
loose cooch yeah um and like discovering
like someone with a real big dick and
like it felt like a virgin yeah and so
like which actually like when he laid it
out I was like that sounds kind of
reasonable but the funny story was that
many years later you know when the
Madonna album erotica came out yeah she
sent him a signed copy of that album
yeah and on it she said it's not about
dicks it's about love inside it
which I thought was like super funny and
I was like yeah okay so she was like no
that's not what the song was about but
honestly
I don't know like if you wanted to read
it that way you're totally could you
totally could that's why these gangsters
are gonna read it well that's
that's what was kind of funny about it
but I think like so this also wasn't the
first movie that because I mean Quentin
Tarantino is very known nowadays like
for doing like non-linear storytelling
you know what I mean
and obviously that had been done before
but I kind of feel like when Reservoir
Dogs came out and then particularly like
two years later when Pulp Fiction came
out where it just had like all these
kind of like really cool gangsters it
was like super violent like with all the
swearing and like also the non-linear
storytelling was jumping back and forth
in time
um that I feel like everybody in the 90s
wanted to make a [ __ ] movie like that
well you know what I mean like all of
these independent filmmakers like oh my
God they all so just there were so many
[ __ ] rip-offs which is crazy because
I wouldn't go to I wouldn't go so far to
say Reservoir Dogs as a rip-off a lot of
people did say that it was um you know
kind of like a Pastiche of a lot of
movies but that's kind of what Quentin
Tarantino does right like he was
um and but he admits it though he's like
well this movie Reservoir Dogs very
massively influenced by the Stanley
Kubrick movie The Killing
um there was also a Chinese uh kind of
heist film called City on fire which he
took like a lot of ideas from but it's
not exactly like any of those he just
kind of like takes all of his and also
he was saying the whole thing about you
know this movie being about a heist that
you never actually see everyone's just
kind of like talking about it he's like
well partially that was done for
budgetary purposes obviously because it
was very low budget but he's like I also
wanted to be kind of like Glengarry
Glenn Ross which was based on a you know
play yeah so he wanted it to have that
theatricality to it where it's like
everybody's talking about this thing
that happened but you never actually see
what happened you know what I mean
everyone's just kind of talking about
effective though it is very very
effective because it leaves things
ambiguous you're not sure if everybody's
telling the truth you don't know who you
know what I mean some dudes may have
been lying about how it really went down
and you know it leaves room because
there's a rat in there somewhere you
find out who he is it was a setup there
was a cop in there on the team I mean I
kind of feel like everybody probably
knows who the who the rat was at this
point you know some people may have
never seen this movie maybe not I mean
and um because I had seen it a long time
ago and I forgot who it was it wasn't
until it's a later I remember who it was
yeah it had been a long time since I'd
seen this so I had forgotten like what
all the like developments were it had
some pretty interesting elements to to
it the uh The Heist was you know it's
kind of they're kind of showing us as as
if it's a real professional
bank robbery you know it was bankruptcy
yeah it was diamonds yeah it was going
to be real professional and they had
like they were all wearing issue
uniforms and issue pistols it was uh
they they were black suits with white
shirts and black ties and they couldn't
use their own names they had to use
cover names and they all had the exact
same gun they were a little Smith and
Wesson uh I think it's uh 5 8 but uh six
eight five five I forgot which which
model number it was just that damn
stainless
do a column nine millimeter automatic
that they had back in the 90s it was
just everywhere
and I was just paying attention to the
guns you know during the show
and Harvey Keitel had two
they were the same but they were
slightly different models
um
he had the square trigger guard one that
everyone was issued and then he had
a round trigger guard so he must have
been carrying his own too
it was just you know there was some
weird stuff that happened you know what
I mean like uh Buscemi that was Mr White
or Mr Pink he's Mr Pink Mr Pink Harvey
Keitel was Mr White he had the same gun
as everybody else but one there's one
shot where he falls and you see it in
his holster and it's a different model
in there I was wondering what the hell
that was all about it was the compact
version in there I guess it looked
better in the holster
so they used that one but so the guns
were it I liked it I liked it but in any
of these kind of movies I'm [ __ ]
really paying attention to the gods
being a gun guy to see if the continuity
is correct and get the thinking is right
it passes the test they had
the gun the guns fit the story I thought
it was kind of cool
Harvey Keitel now that you bring him up
um is actually one of the guys you have
to thank for this movie being the way it
was because initially the idea for this
movie was to make it for 30 grand which
is all that Tarantino and his producer
had at the time and they were going to
make it in black and white as his first
movie was but it so happened that the
script for this was kind of like the guy
that was going to be the producer on it
whose name was Bender I think Joseph
Bender or something like that and he was
actually going to be in the movie too
he was in an acting class
and his acting teacher I don't know who
the acting teacher was but the acting
teacher's wife happened to know Harvey
Keitel and she passed the script to
Harvey Keitel and Harvey Keitel loved
the script so much that he contacted
Quentin Tarantino and said I will not
only like co-produce this movie I will
help you raise money for it and I'll be
in the movie too and he paid for them to
fly to New York and do like a casting
thing out there which is where they got
timed for who
um for he paid for like Quentin
Tarantino and the producer everybody
liked to fly out to New York and like
set up a casting okay thing like and
that's where they got like I said Tim
Roth who I don't know if you know but
he's a British actor
um and they got Michael Madsen and uh I
think like one other actor so they when
they got out went out to New York to do
it so Harvey Keitel actually got like I
said the original movie was just gonna
cost 30 grand because that's what they
had but Harvey Keitel like him being
involved in it they actually raised is
like one and a half million wow for you
know for him being involved and they got
like people that were you know but big
names and [ __ ] like that I mean people
like Steve Buscemi and Tim Roth and
stuff like that were not huge names but
they were they were kind of like up and
comers I think at the time yeah this
movie made Steve Buscemi yeah it's me
and that was supposed to be Jon Cryer
actually that was who was gonna be that
role originally but yeah this is the
first time I remember when this came out
was the first time I'd ever seen Steve
Buscemi and I liked the guy he reminded
me of my my buddy uh Mike look my if my
buddy Mike looks just like that but um
and uh
I think I think bushimi's career was
built on on this movie because he's so
good yeah because all of his roles were
kind of like this after this you know he
ended up in a lot of
a lot of like [ __ ] criminal type
movies you know he plays kind of a bad
guy but like a likable bad guy
in one movie He plays a serial killer I
forgot which one that was oh yeah I have
to look that up
he was in Fargo too wasn't he now that
I'm thinking about all that stuff yeah
like Helen brother because he did a lot
of movies with the cone players actually
and Keitel ended up in more um Quentin
Tarantino movies so I guess they started
working together because he was in Pulp
Fiction too yeah and I think he was in a
couple others yeah he was like the
cleaner yeah well and the thing about
well Samuel L Jackson actually
auditioned for this movie but didn't get
it
and uh so Quentin Tarantino was like
yeah but you can be in my next movie
though like because Samuel L Jackson
said I blew the audition like for this
one but
um but Tarantino liked him so much that
he actually I think he actually like had
him in mind for the part like in Pulp
Fiction oh speaking of Pulp Fiction too
I re I realized this when I was watching
it is that um you know Mr blonde Michael
madsen's character his last name when
they actually say what his last name is
is Vega and I said oh he must be related
to John Travolta's character from Pulp
Fiction because that guy's last name is
Vega too yeah like it's Vincent Vega and
this guy is Vic Vega and yeah they're
both in the same they're supposed to be
brothers and Tarantino was actually
gonna make a movie about both of them
like but they got too old like you know
by the time he got around to doing it
and also I think that one of the radio
ads like because you know one of the uh
threads going through the movie is them
listening to like K Billy's like 70s
sounds of the 70s or whatever
um there's a radio commercial for
Jackrabbit Slims which was the diner
from Pulp Fiction where Uma Thurman and
John Travolta were like dancing there's
another thing in there it might be an
Easter egg Harvey Keitel
um what's his name the boss what's the
boss's name Joe Joe yeah uh Joe is
asking kaitel or uh what was his covered
name Mr Wade
Jackson Mr White if if he had seen
Alabama and he goes no I haven't seen
her you know or you know she's doing
something else or and evidently it was
somebody that he that was around him
while he was doing some robberies that
could be talking about Alabama Worley
who was
the uh the girl that was in Pulp Fiction
that character the one that uh I thought
you said True Romance in True Romance
yeah you know what I said no you said
Pulp Fiction oh no I'm not true romance
in True Romance which
Tarantino what wrote the script there's
a one of the main characters is Alabama
Worley so that's probably
it may have been who who that who yeah
he's having like an extended Universe
yeah yeah
which actually I think I think True
Romance is a better movie than this but
this is a good movie
I haven't seen True Romance in a long
time like I said you know Tarantino did
write the screenplay for that but uh
Tony Scott directed it I put I put um
True Romance maybe as good or a little
bit better than Pulp Fiction but they're
different they're different tone but
yeah you but they do feel like they're
in the same universe
somebody said um my Ben said yes we do
that Tim Roth is English I was actually
asking Tom if he knew this if he knew
that Tim Roth was or uh Tim Roth was
English because I didn't know if you
knew I don't even know who that is the
guy that played Mr Orange
which guy was that the guy that got shot
like that shot that was like laying down
no I couldn't tell he had a funny accent
but I just thought he said he was having
a hard time like he was having a hard
time with the with the American accent
um and he actually he was in uh Pulp
Fiction too that could have been so he
played he was British in that that could
have been somewhere up Northeast though
there are people that kind of sound like
that to me you know yeah and to be
honest you don't really hear him talking
normally until later because at the
beginning like you know he's been shot
yeah so he's just like mostly screaming
yeah for like the first half of the
movie I think that's like that's such a
great
I mean this really has one of the best
kind of
um openers you know what I mean because
they just open on that Diner scene where
they're all sitting around like talking
about [ __ ] yeah right they're
talking about the Madonna song and then
they're talking about
um you know Mr Pink like Steve Buscemi's
character how he doesn't believe in
tipping so there was that hot kind of
whole thing and then they just do that
great iconic like scene where they're
all just like walking down the street in
slow motion like over the credits and
then it like smash cuts to Mr orange gut
shot in the back of Mr White's car and
he's just like screaming that he's dying
and they're freaking out and so it like
yeah so like it jumps ahead till after
to after the heist and you can tell that
it went horribly horribly wrong because
they don't know where anybody else is at
that point and it's just that really
gets you engaged right away and I think
that was like a really good
I think the way that he structured it
you know what I mean like the way that
he you know did it non-linear but I
think that's really good because it just
kind of reveals build upon reveals and
he seems to know exactly when to do like
a flashback but it doesn't really feel
like a cheesy ass flashback you know
what I mean another thing nothing about
it is that this is a good lesson and how
to do dialogue yeah
it kind of reminds me of alien one where
the crew the Nostromo just kind of talks
over each other and they talk and they
feel like real people it's not like
actors saying lines and in that dialogue
the way they're interacting with each
other you already figure out what the
hierarchy is who's who what people's
personalities are like
and just in a real natural flowing
conversation and this kind of has that
not quite as good as alien one but
still effective still effective because
you don't have all the backstory of all
these guys
you're just going by their accents uh
how they're delivering lines what their
emotions are at the time and what
they're talking about and you can get a
feel for for who they are as characters
you know I like that I mean ideally
that's what you should be shooting for
in a movie like this yeah you because
you don't want to that's kind of one of
the you know very like characteristics
that's one of the first things they kind
of teach you in a like screenwriting
classes or anything like that is it's
kind of like a show don't tell you don't
want that you don't want them to be like
dumping Exposition on you or like
explaining what they're gonna do you
want them just inter and Quentin
Tarantino I was reading like a little
bit of an interview with him earlier
where he was talking about this movie
and he said you know the thing about it
he's like most people don't talk about
the characters want to talk about the
plot because you're if you're a person
you don't talk about the plot you just
talk about [ __ ] yeah you just want
things to be revealed while you're
talking about [ __ ] because that's
how real life is yeah good examples you
know Harvey Keitel doing Mr White
he's talking about the situation mostly
and and
um uh you know after Mr orange gets shot
he stands up for him
you you know you're just on the way he's
delivering the material
you know he's been to prison you know
he's a professional criminal a a Thief
based uh and you know doing robberies
you know that
he's going to get the job done if you
try to stop him he'll shoot you
but you also know he's compassionate he
stands up for people he's a good guy you
know he's a good he's as good as you can
be and still be a criminal I mean he'll
shoot a cop if a cop's in his way he
doesn't think twice about it yeah or
yeah uh but in their in their
rationality in their rationale that cops
in the game and this is just a game but
he also didn't approve of them just
shooting random civilians and stuff yeah
he got really upset about Mr blonde like
he was like calling him psychotic and
he's like I don't want to work with that
yeah he goes did you see that black girl
how old was that black girl 20 and the
other guy says if that Mr Block just
shot some yo black girl yeah you know he
was upset about all that he was just
shooting people
later on Mr blondes like well they hit
the alarm I told him not to hit the
alarm
yeah so he he just figured well once
they did like what I told them not to do
then they're you know then they had
already signed their death warranty he
didn't care about it yeah but Mr White
wouldn't have done that he said never
done it he's just trying he says he
didn't want to he he wasn't there to
kill anybody he's just this is just a
job it's not personal
and he just he's just there to get it
done and get out
um but he talks about you know bashing
somebody in the face uh you know if they
if they don't listen uh but he says but
if I'm trying to get out of there and
when he say if if I got to choose
between shooting somebody and doing 10
years in prison that's no choice right
he said that that that's you know yeah
he'll do what he has to do but he won't
go out of his way to like just to kill
civilians or anything like that yeah
there's even kind of like a funny
exchange like that whole that whole
scene between Mr White and Mr Pink like
in the that bathroom or whatever is
really really good where you know Mr
Pink is kind of like um you know how
many cops got shot and he's like or how
many cops did you shoot and he's like
yeah however many cops he shot and he's
like how about any real people
well one he says two he said a couple
the other guy said a couple and he goes
you're shooting you're real people he
goes no
yeah well like I said and that was kind
of the big
the big uh issue that he had with it
while like why the job started to go
sideways is because he perceived Mr
blonde as just like going psychotic and
just like starting to shoot random
civilians
um and I kind of like I said that's
where the point where he thought that it
went off the rails is because he was
just like shooting all these random
people yeah and then
um I like too that you don't really find
out like Mr Blue the guy that plays Mr
Blue was actually like a real criminal
um you know not anymore like not but you
don't see him much he was like an older
guy and he only had the beginning yeah
yeah at the very beginning like when
he's like when Joe is like telling all
of them about it and he's
um
and you actually never do figure out
they say that he died but they don't
show that I think that they as far as I
know like I think Tarantino shot a scene
or they wanted to shoot a scene where
you saw Mr Blue get killed but they
couldn't afford to shoot it or something
like that because you do eventually see
Mr Brown which is Quentin Tarantino's
character you do eventually see how he
got killed because they say at the
beginning yeah I I know he got killed
because I saw him get shot in the head
or whatever because they were trying to
like carjack or that was like that was
when Mr orange got shot was it yeah when
they were trying to carjack and get the
[ __ ] out of there it's just a a good
movie tight
that's just the whole thing is just
hinged on this dialogue good writing and
good performances there's there is some
action
but it's not an action movie
um although the scenes that do have
action they're very short but they're
intense and it's because they did a good
job
of uh characterizing these characters so
you kind of care about what's happening
to them so it's it's a very good
well-made movie made on a budget I mean
they're all criminals but they very they
have their own personalities you know
what I mean the beginning of them just
shooting the [ __ ]
Tarantino's kind of pulled you into
their world so now you're kind of like
you care more about these guys
it's kind of like you're one of them
yeah I think that was the estab the
establishing shot where you're in the
diner is to get you on board with these
guys even though they're clearly
criminals but they're people that you
want to hang out with because they're
like kind of funny and they're just like
hanging out and that really kind of
draws you in and like I said I think
that's such a great thing because it's
like it's making you kind of chummy with
these guys sitting down at the diner
having breakfast with everybody and then
he throws you right into the scene where
Mr orange is like you know bleeding to
death like in the back seat of the car
it's just like a really really good like
juxtaposition yeah that oh that opening
scene is like something out of Glengarry
Glenn Ross yeah pulling you into the
world of salesmen in freaking Glenn Gary
Glen Rock yeah pulling you into the
world of these damn thieves
that's another movie we should probably
do one of these things Gary yeah because
I haven't seen that along Mickey Roma
and I remember being that really really
good yeah it's fun movie but yeah that
was that's another one we should do but
yeah and over the leads yeah the leads
yeah the Greg Gary leads
to like um that they I think it was
Danny he said that they thought Mr Pink
should have lived Mr Pink did live he
was the only I think he was the only one
that did but he got arrested though
they didn't show him getting arrested
but I'm pretty sure he would have got
arrested because he picked up what I
presumed was the diamonds like on the
way out
but then like you heard sirens and [ __ ]
like that like at the very end so I'm
presuming that Mr Pink because at first
I thought that he had escaped like with
the diamonds because he was the only one
that knew where the diamonds were right
yeah but he said he had him stashed yeah
or oh but then I thought well did it did
Joe Cabot like know where the diamonds
were because he came in and he had like
a little I don't know like the little
case and I presumed those were the
diamonds because Mr Pink like leaned
down and picked it up like before he
left at my house I don't know but it was
wasn't really paying attention to the
diamonds yeah I mean he wasn't looking
for him but maybe that's what that was I
thought that's what that was because why
would he picked them up you know what I
mean but that's I mean
and then there's kind of the other
controversy too at the end
um whether
Mr White shot or killed Mr Orange
like that's the other controversy
although I'm I'm team yeah I think he
did
um David June said is the audio cutting
in and out for anyone else Tammy said
sounds okay here yeah yeah I hope maybe
that's just you yeah maybe that's just
you
they're talking about
um killing Zoe which yeah I remember
that being good too I remember that
being good too but
um so one thing that you mentioned when
we were watching the movie and last
night and I think a lot of people kind
of think this
um the very very famous probably the
most famous scene where Mr blonde
Michael Madsen like cuts that cop's ear
off
yeah and you had said that you
remembered that being a lot more graphic
than it was I remember actually seeing
him cut it off but he didn't isn't that
crazy he doesn't show it yeah it's just
kind of like and I use this example a
lot but it's just kind of like how
people remember
um like for example The Texas Chainsaw
Massacre like you you think you remember
Franklin the guy in the wheelchair
getting like eviscerated by the chainsaw
but you don't you don't see anything you
just see him from the back you don't see
like anything happen and it's the same
thing in Reservoir Dogs like a lot of
people are like oh my God they cut that
dude's ear off but they don't he just
goes like that with the with the
straight razor and then it pans over
yeah you don't see it and then like he
they he does have this ever deer in his
hand which actually really made me laugh
when he's just like hey hey can I can
you hear me I was like hey I'm like
that's so [ __ ] up but it's like it's
so funny Michael Madsen was so good in
that and it's like it's funny because
um he apparently really had a hard time
like with doing the violence in that
scene especially
like because he had to cut that dude's
um face and everything and when the guy
that played the cop you know like when
he's gonna burn him to death like he's
poured all the gasoline on him and he
says I have a little kid at home or
something like that that was an ad-lib
okay like that wasn't in the script and
Michael Madsen they said he had just had
a kid yeah and so like that freaked him
out like a little bit because he's just
like oh [ __ ] I don't want to do it now
because it like really really bothered
him because that was like that was a
really good ad-lib though because it
like added a lot to that scene but uh
but yes and I kind of feel like
that Steelers wheel song Stuck In The
Middle With You is probably like ruined
forever because of its association with
them
that quick Quentin Tarantino maybe like
for all his faults like later on because
he did become
not in this not in exactly the same way
that maybe Tim Burton did but you know
you know how Tim Burton like he came out
and he was like all this big like you
know original and everything but now
like everybody is like Tim Burton me
yeah you know what I'm saying he's like
he's like he's like he's like a meme or
like a brand at this point and it's a so
I kind of feel like Tarantino had that a
little bit happen to him too yeah I
think he redeemed himself though with
Once Upon a Time in Hollywood yeah yeah
because that was a [ __ ] fantastic
movie yeah I know that maybe there were
some people that didn't like it I loved
that movie I thought it was so so funny
and hateful eight was good too yeah I
like table yeah
um really it's just like a few of his
movies that I didn't super love yeah
some of it it got too [ __ ] ridiculous
like the one uh
the one the war movie one well in
glorious basket yeah yeah that one was
just too [ __ ] ridiculous
um
I thought Kill Bill was too [ __ ]
ridiculous I didn't like it oh I like
skill Bell yeah everybody else seems to
like it I didn't like it well I mean
Kill Bill was supposed to be an homage
to like those over the top yeah like
Hong Kong yeah like action maybe you
know what I mean so it was supposed to
be like it wasn't supposed to be
realistic I just thought it was dumb
yeah well I mean you know
um some I can understand some people
might like it but I didn't really care
for it this one was like like I said it
tried to be more realistic but in like a
theatricality type of way it's funny
because I think when Harvey Keitel like
when him and uh Quentin Tarantino were
working on this movie like and Harvey
catel had read the script he's like oh
did you grow up in a really rough
neighborhood or did you have like
parents that were criminals or gangsters
or something like that and Quentin
tareness said Tarantino said no I just
watched a lot of movies yeah
so it's like so it's kind of realistic
in that sense but it's also like has a
theatricality to it yeah which is not
which is like heightened reality I guess
like a little bit like it's not I don't
know like it's not super realistic but
it's in a way that sounds realistic like
when you see it in a film you know what
I mean uh David June said I love his
dumb [ __ ] uh Django I still haven't seen
uh Django Unchained by the way hatefully
it kill Bill it's all silly nonsense
um and then they're saying uh Ben says I
think the only actual blood in Texas
Chainsaw Massacre is where the
hitchhiker cuts the annoying wheel the
wheelchair guy not even sure if the meat
hook impalement has blood it doesn't
because you don't see that from the back
either you see that from the front like
when he hangs around the thing I think
the only blood you see is when it when
the he cuts his hand like in the van
I don't even think you see any blood
with the with the wheelchair because you
just see it from the back
uh David June said yeah shooting Hitler
in the face while burning him to death
was ridiculous
I was I don't know like I don't like
um I like his silly movies I don't like
them as much as you know Pulp Fiction or
Reservoir Dogs or once upon a time in
Hollywood that were more I mean Once
Upon a Time in Hollywood kind of got a
little bit ridiculous at the end but in
an acceptably ridiculous kind of way
you were laughing I was laughing I was
laughing because it built up to that
yeah so you know I understood it and uh
also the one that had uh the one that
had Crustle in it Death Proof wasn't too
wasn't bad that was pretty good yeah I
liked that one a lot too yeah that one
was a lot of dialogue as well but I
liked that because I liked all the
characters yeah death poop is pretty
good
yeah that's right yeah I'd probably did
we did we do that one I don't think we
we need to do it I don't I think we saw
it but I don't think we reviewed it yeah
because I remember watching it not too
long ago like I saw it in the theater
like I said I saw you know when they did
um when it came out and it was
Grindhouse and it was the two movies you
know what I mean and then it had like
all the fake trailers in the middle I
went I saw it like in the theater and
they played it like all in one thing
like that which is cool but yeah I don't
even know if you can see that like that
anymore unless you do it yourself
but I mean I was gonna say that um the
[ __ ] music in this is great that was
another thing that was really
influential particularly like for
independent films in the 90s was that
I kind of feel like prior to this
Independent films like they didn't have
the money to put like kind of big hits
or anything in there so it always kind
of had to just be you know not not stock
music but nothing that was all that
exciting but after this like it seemed
like every Indie movie had to be like
cool and have like a really really cool
it was soundtrack you know what I mean
there was one shot that I remember
standing out during the day during the
day that this came out and it did it
again when I watched it that was when um
he's inside listening listening to the
to Stuck In The Middle With You yeah
and he goes outside and the camera
follows him and he walks across the
street and he gets quiet and he goes to
the truck and gets the gasoline and
comes back you didn't see that you know
Tarantino said that was his favorite
sequence in the movie yeah because you
don't see that normally you follow that
and the change in Ambiance from being
inside of a dab loud Warehouse with that
music and then going outside and this
dude just calmly walking and getting the
gas and then going right going back it
just felt like you're with the dude yeah
like it like it really happened
I think that that's just really funny
that you brought that up because like I
said Tarantino said that was his very
favorite sequence in the movie like
because well because yeah because you
get you walk outside like and you just
hear like the sounds of L.A yeah like
little kids laughing and like cars like
traffic and stuff like that like it was
like a normal yep kind of [ __ ] yeah it
was like back into this [ __ ] place
where he's torturing this dude right
like it was the most like it was just
normal like there was normal [ __ ] going
on and you didn't know what was going on
out there like yeah that was like a
really really good I mean this this
movie is just like full of
I mean there's it's iconic for a reason
it's just kind of full of like [ __ ]
it's got great music in it like perfect
perfect music choices which Tarantino is
always really good at like the dialogue
is hilarious
um you know and it's just like so sharp
and it's just
I don't know I just feel like this this
and Pulp Fiction or probably liked it
they probably teach this in uh
screenwriting classes I'd imagine like
in how to write dialogue and things like
that because
yo I think he let I think he let them
ad-lib a lot of it too
yeah maybe I don't know I haven't seen
the actual like I said now I do know
that one line about the kid was that was
that was ad-libbed but I don't know it
sounds like it was just pulled out of
their ass it does yeah I mean yeah yeah
and uh which that's good thing you know
if you have good actors and you got a
good director and you and they're all in
on it then they can you can just let
them run you know yeah because I mean
they do you know before they shot this I
think they rehearsed right for two or
three weeks right you know so you get
into all your characters you get to know
like everybody else's characters and all
their timing and everything like that so
you can kind of play off of each other
um yeah Richard Brown said Jackie Brown
uh is my fave yeah that's a good one too
that's another one we should probably do
David says we'll send him uh you can
read what he said uh after the show
shoot me the new address I'll happily
send hateful eight or Django to y'all
because that would be a fun review okay
because I would appreciate that okay
I'll send yeah don't let me forget like
I'll send you the new uh new address
so yeah I don't have hateful hateful
eight or or Django yeah
and Camp guy said I love Jackie Brown
yeah we should probably do that one too
that's like his take on like black
exploitation yeah Pam Grier was in that
yeah I like it you probably would like
it it might be on 2B I think it was like
a few like a couple weeks ago I saw it
on there all right so are are you ready
to yeah I'm gonna go down and cook oh
he's gonna go down and cook okay that's
what I thought he was getting got
everything all yeah I got a little bit
fancy yeah I got everything prepped up I
was trying to think if there was
anything else I wanted to cover about
this one Thai chicken curry going on
down Oh Boy Fresh stuff out of the damn
Garden in there fresh stuff out of the
garden yeah all right so yeah Reservoir
Dogs go see it if you haven't seen it uh
I think it's on I think it's on Hulu and
like I said you can really see like
Tarantino is one of those guys that just
came out almost like kind of like fully
formed you know what I mean
um but we'll probably do Pulp Fiction
uh next so it'll be I don't know maybe
Sunday or next Tuesday or something like
that we'll probably do it because like I
said we still got to do Godfather two
and three at some point too so you know
what I mean all right so tomorrow is our
main show because tomorrow's Wednesday
and we're gonna do a show about guess
what the Moonies oh okay so that's gonna
be the next show that's gonna be
tomorrow night so hopefully all of you
guys can make it thank you for dropping
by today and I will will both see you
again tomorrow bye